excuse me joining me now on stage here
at e3 2015 on the gamespot stage is ian
from giants Pharaoh Ian we're here to
talk about a game with like pretty one
of the more sort of evocative and
mysterious titles here at e3 what
remains of Edith Finch I what are you
trying to get out of people with that
title what are you trying to what you
feeling are you trying to evoke I think
we're trying to make people feel like
there's an element of mystery and a
little ominous and a little classy as
well so we're trying to evoke like weird
fiction from like the 1900s or so like
lovecraft and bore haze and a little
Neil Gaiman and something that feels you
know like a story that you're sitting
down to hear something that's like maybe
you know like an old tale I think that's
a really i love the third adjective
classy because you know you talk about
mysterious things you talk about
intriguing things sure but the style
that class that's sort of that that
level of you know of class we're here at
its it definitely is very telling it
helps sort of define the kind of game
you're making in the kind of mood you're
setting so give us for folks who aren't
familiar with it sort of give us the
elevator the line sure we'll delve into
what we're seeing yeah it's a hard thing
people come up on the show floor and
then like so is this like a like action
game it was your even though what kind
of game right right leg live in three
words so the the short description is
that it's a collection of short stories
it's a stories about a family in
Washington State and you play as edith
finch and you're coming back to the
house that you grew up in and as you
explore this house you're finding
stories of each of the family members
and each of these stories is about how
that family member died so over the
course of the game you're exploring
pretty large house and several
generations of your family's past you
know a lot of families keep photo albums
some chronicle events in the family
bible the finches just how everyone died
well they died in pretty interesting
ways so it kind of makes sense I think
when you play the game that this is
something that you know them are our
Diaries like that's kind of the easiest
way to tell the story sure but one of
the things that I'm really excited about
is that because we're telling these
stories about
you know a group of people we can have
even though in a given story like that
family member is going to die by the end
of it that has repercussions later on so
some of our stories are things that come
from like the culture at large so if you
look at something like the Hatfields and
McCoys or something like a feud uh-huh
that's something that you look
interesting in his own right but it also
has this kind of larger life in the
culture outside so some of the stories
that come later on are things that are
sort of like tellings of like what
people might imagine has happened sort
of the pinnacle beyond what act the
confines of just one family's own
situation although when it comes to the
finches the confines of their situation
is this giant sprawling towering house
uh is this I mean the house itself you
know if you're talk you're talking about
a collection of short stories the house
looks like a collection of houses yeah
that's exactly right and the house has
become this concrete version of what the
whole game is about which he has a lot
of abstract ideas of this family and
death and you know man versus nature
Jack carpeting yes 1970s bathroom that
was the direction of the artists like
making bathroom the fields 1970s and I
think they nailed it but the house is
you know this collection of the
different generations so one of the
things in the mythology the Finch family
is that whenever someone dies they just
shut the bedroom door and nobody goes in
there anymore and it becomes sort of a
monument to that person so with a large
family you end up kind of running out of
space so each of the generations builds
on to the house and each floor of the
house is actually a different generation
of the family so as you're going through
kind of from bottom to top of the house
you're also seeing the history what a
fascinating idea because that's I mean
that's you're basically turning the
house into you're turning into a family
tree you're turning it into a mausoleum
a living mausoleum you're turning it
into it it takes on just sort of
exponentially more meaning and you know
when you're trying to tell a narrative
story in the game exponentially more
meaning to play with just makes it all
better yeah I like our last game
unfinished Swan you know this is the
game that's really about exploring and
one of the things that I think games do
really well is exploring space so in
this game we're trying to make the sense
of exploring space fit the narrative you
know desires of trying to explore this
family
and the house is emerged is like a
really kind of it seems obvious in
hindsight but it's something that took a
year to you know for us to really figure
out and kind of consolidate on and it's
it's pretty insane I mean the scale of
this house and yeah I'm really happy
where we are I think some of the I think
it's kind of a mark of a great a really
great idea when it seems obvious in
hindsight right when you come around to
a place like oh of course we're gonna do
it that way that's the best way you know
you're doing it the best way so we're
looking at sort of some clips of the
game in action here and in addition to
its first person exploration it's hard
to eat we can't hear it here on the
stage at e3 but we've seen words writing
across the screen is there this
combination of sort of the written word
the spoken word in in order to convey
the story ya know one of the things that
we're trying to do is to remind players
at all times that they're hearing a
story that they're not actually this
character there's someone who even
they're not during a hawk laughing yeah
yeah yeah this may or may not have
happened and in this in this case the
story that you're seeing is the very
first story people are gonna find in the
house it's Molly Finch who's a
ten-year-old girl and she wakes up and
she's starving she's super super hungry
so she goes around trying to find
something to eat and she's so hungry
that she ends up imagine yourself
becoming this series of animals eating
bigger and bigger prey which she is what
we're seeing here can I tell you that
these two scenes alone have just won my
heart over to your game because I think
one of the like fantastic opportunity
spaces that still exists in games is
conveying the feeling of being an animal
is taking that animal experience and
somehow making gameplay around it so I'm
just fascinated and super delighted that
you guys are taking that on oh thanks I
think you're going to enjoy this very
cool I well you know telling those
different stories and having different
short stories means not only can you
experiment with who the player character
is where the player character is but
also sort of the tone of each story and
you know we described earlier we talked
in the earlier about the overall kind of
thing you're going for in terms of
mystery intriguing that weird fiction
vibe but
from character to character are you guys
taking making changes sort of
aesthetically and in locations that
really help sort of magnify that
personality yeah we're trying to make
every story feel a little distinct from
each other partly because that's just
kind of the games we make like their
games that are about exploring and I
think the more variety you can throw at
people the more destabilize they are
because gamers you know generally people
play a lot of games and they're very
familiar with with how things work so
they have this mindset of like how do I
you know get to the end and the more you
can mix it up the more you keep them in
that state of like always kind of
wondering what's happening and I think
that that matches really well with what
Edith is doing in this house like she's
she doesn't know what's out there she's
exploring it and each of these stories
is really about the characters
confronting the unknown so we want to
make sure players have that same
experience and we also want to make
something that felt like a family and I
think it's it's true that in every
family yeah it's just a collection of
weirdos you know like people are so
different from person to person and it
felt like each of these stories you know
aside from the fact that they take place
at different time periods in different
times a year or different locations you
know they're the perspective of the
person so it's like how this person kind
of imagines the world and can see the
things in the world that you know they
find themselves in that I think that's
the fascinating dichotomy of a family
right it's no one you know from a lot of
your life there's no one like them in
terms of how you know them how well you
know them as a person you don't know
people the way you know family you
aren't connected to them and the way you
know family at the same time decide that
intimacy is the fact that you're
distinct people and you nobody knows the
world the way you do and yeah it was
your world and so and you're history
yeah and you're history in the way you
perceive things so it's kind of this the
intimacy and the this is foreignness
like it right next to each other and I
think that's just a fascinating concept
to explore in a game yeah and it's
really hard to make a game that's about
exploring a family I mean it's not like
something that you can just you know go
off and give a bunch of designers and
have them come back with something so
this is kind of our version of that you
know where we're dealing with a lot of
very abstract ideas of you know the
sublime horror of nature and the way
that you know people approached death
and and so I mean we really just have a
bunch of these crazy store
these and it's nice that they all kind
of end up converging naturally because
they come from like exploring a lot of
the same you know sorts of feelings it
really like what is it like as a small
fragile creature in a perilous universe
you know to find yourself confronting
the unknown and unfortunately it ended
up not working out very well for these
people but you know I think that's just
true that says as tiny human beings you
know we have a limited ability to
understand or affect our environment and
you know this game is really about what
happens to people you know when they
kind of come up against those problems
in fascinating to talk to you and hear
you talk about the design philosophy
behind what remains of Edith Finch and
see the ways it's already manifesting in
the game I can't wait to get my hands on
it I you gotta release dating a platform
in mines next year and it's a
PlayStation 4 exclusive fantastic Ian
from Giants Pharaoh thank you so much
for copiaste Joe as a pleasure that's
what remains of Edith Finch ladies and
gentlemen here on the gamespot stage at
e3 2015 we've got another demo coming
right up don't go away